this gear spins around 86 times a second
but this gear spins around just once
every 10.3 billion years the RPM of the
first gear is the same as the BPM of the
fastest heart rate ever recorded that of
an amethyst woodstar hummingbird but the
last gear is so slow before it makes
even one revolution our son will have
died the fact that my team can take
every nutty idea I have and make it a
reality scares me subscribers will be
getting one of these this year but it
takes so long to make them if you join
now yours will come in the spring in the
meantime we will send you what everyone
else is getting in the spring 100 karats
of diamond I'm not kidding the value we
place on diamonds is the result of
marketing now you knew that but you
still would like a sparkly minute every
now and then and at least one of the
four C's that's why we put 20 G of tiny
real diamonds into a sandtimer it asks a
lot of questions about truth beauty and
time